yesterday after donald trump abruptly
tweeted out
no second coronavirus stimulus after
conversations with mitch mcconnell and
other lawmakers the speaker of the house
nancy pelosi
got on a phone call with house democrats
and they were talking about donald trump
tweeting out
we're not doing a second stimulus which
seems like it seems like
the last opportunity trump had to do
something to actually gain some votes in
this upcoming election and nancy pelosi
suggested or wondered whether donald
trump's use
of the steroid dexamethasone for
treatment of his coronavirus
might be impacting donald trump's
decision-making ability because
even for the standards that we have come
to expect
for donald trump his behavior is out of
control
and last night hit and indeed donald
trump
appeared to have had a steroid-induced
manic episode on twitter
if you imagine the scene at the white
house
which at this point i don't know if the
white house is more like a psych ward
or a biohazard unit at this point i
guess it's like
a biohazard psych ward donald trump
would not stop tweeting last night
things
that make absolutely no sense and it is
again raising questions about whether
donald trump is experiencing
mania as a result of the drugs he is on
to treat coronavirus now as i told you
earlier this week
it's not just observers from the outside
that have these concerns donald trump jr
as gabriel sherman wrote in vanity fair
on monday
uh donald trump jr reportedly
is worried that donald trump is manic
and wants to stage an intervention and
as we've talked about before
corticosteroid-induced mania is not an
uncommon side effect
from the drugs that donald trump has
been taking donald trump already has a
tendency to have this sort of
up-down manic and then depressed periods
or or episodes
and last night was completely crazy okay
so look look at what is going on and
remember
this is not some obscure political
advisor or a podcast host
this is the president of the united
states at 7
41 pm eastern last night donald trump
tweeted
i have fully authorized the total
declassification
of any and all documents pertaining to
the single
greatest political crime in american
history the russia
hoax likewise the hillary clinton email
scandal
no redactions so it's a crazy tweet it's
already wacky
but then 40 minutes later donald trump
tweets
about these same documents which he
supposedly just declassified
trump tweets quote all russia hoax
scandal
information was declassified by me long
ago
what you you just said you're
declassifying it now
trump goes on to say unfortunately for
our country
people have acted very slowly especially
since it is perhaps
the biggest political crime in the
history of our country notice
in neither tweet does trump actually say
what crime was committed
that's a theme but long ago you
declassified it
40 minutes earlier he announced he was
declassifying these documents
and 40 minutes later he says i actually
declassified this stuff long ago
people are even on the right concerned
about the mental state of donald trump
and whether this is being impacted by
the steroids that he is on
it continued all night it kept going
this morning seemingly nobody able to
get donald trump under control
the speculation is that this is literal
roid rage the president roid raging on
twitter
for hours trump projecting about joe
biden saying quote
i just hope the voter understands that
they are all
fake news trying hard to push a man that
should never be president of our country
it sounds like he's referring to himself
there in 2016
right-wing media eventually when the
republican primary
was over uh getting in line and pushing
for trump
who should never have been president of
the united states
trump again erratically after stopping
the second coronavirus stimulus just
hours
earlier out of the blue trump tweets
quote
if i am sent a standalone bill for
stimulus checks
twelve hundred dollars they will go out
to our great people
immediately i am ready to sign right now
are you listening nancy this was just
hours
after he stopped negotiations and said
we're not
doing a second coronavirus stimulus
again
is this some kind of roid rage is trump
thinking clearly
did someone get to him and say which by
the way would have been good advice
mr president sir as he likes to say
um the stock market imploded when you
tweeted no second stimulus
it was sort of like the last opportunity
in these 27
28 as of yesterday days before the
election
to do something good for the american
people and maybe regain some votes
maybe trump realized what am i doing
i'll now tweet i would sign
stimulus checks making no sense trump
then
inventing a new number system tweeting
eleven
comma double zero so that's not uh
i i don't know uh you know what kind of
format that is one one
comma zero zero north carolina residents
get incorrect voter registration forms
2 000 la county voters received faulty
ballots
with no way to vote for president many
others
throughout usa here we go
this will be the most corrupt election
in american history then trump
again after saying remember no more
second stimulus
tweets to demand stimulus money
for airlines tweeting quote the house
and senate
should immediately approve 25 billion
dollars
for airline payroll support and 135
billion dollars
for paycheck protection programs
um for small business both
of these will be fully paid for with
unused
funds from the cares act have this money
i will sign now and then a tweet
that is both completely incoherent but
very disturbing donald trump saying
quote
i don't even know what this means so i
had to constantly
fight off all this scum achieve
more than any other president in first
term
and then they talk chaos they
created crimes against me and
this administration there are dozens
more
but the point here is trump is more out
of control than usual
and just imagine the scene at the white
house
trump already difficult to control trump
now
is on steroids which can cause mania
euphoria and delusions of grandeur and
anyone who wants to go near trump has to
wear full ppe
based on a report that we've gotten why
because trump has coronavirus and he is
presumably still contagious
unless he actually has had it for way
longer than we've been told
in which case he might be past the
contagious phase the the only
alternative
to trump still being contagious is that
they really
lied about when trump first tested
positive it is a man
crumbling before our very eyes a new
poll has him down 21.
so where are we right now we could be
if we get the job done we could be
getting to the end
of this global nightmare but it depends
on you going out to vote
it depends on me going out to vote
believe me i'm going to vote i would
crawl over broken glass to vote i would
crawl
over shards of i don't know send me
creative people please send me some more
metaphors i can use
akin to crawling over glass to vote i
would like to be uh
loaded up with some good ones for the
for the last four weeks of this campaign
we can move on to the end of this
national nightmare we have the
opportunity there's 27 days to go
every single day the trump
administration
shows us what happens when anti-science
christian conservatives have power in
government
on everything from climate change to
fighting this pandemic
we cannot afford another four years of
donald trump one of our sponsors today
is the free thought equality super pac
both
they and i want to remind you that
voting against donald trump in the
presidential election
is one of the most important things you
can do right now if you want
religious conservatives to have less
power and you want science to have more
influence in government make sure you're
registered to vote
make the commitment to vote on or before
november 3rd
i also encourage you to check out the
center for free thought equality
which is an advocacy group that promotes
evidence-based
public policy and supports secular
candidates running for office becoming a
member is completely free
gives you access to tons of excellent
resources related
to secularism in politics just visit
cfequality.org
you can find the link right underneath
this video this message
was paid for by the free thought
equality super pac
and is not authorized by any candidate
or candidates committee